you know over the years Hollywood has
told many stories that reflect the
ideals of the black lives matter
movement so starting this week we are
going to help reintroduce you to some of
them starting with the 2018 drama the
hate you give one of the first films of
its of its kind and so it is a lot of
pressure because you do have so many
people relying on you
you know that and the movie people will
be talking about it and start a
conversation the images mirror what
we're seeing across the nation us
reading the script we're like finally
it's not really a movement for us today
Gordon heights is reeling after the
shooting of a 17 year old black teenager
by a white police officer we live in a
complicated world it doesn't seem that
complicated to you we've been telling
y'all yo we getting shot help it's just
that now with you know with with new
devices and social media people are now
like okay it's super the title the hate
you give is inspired by the concept of
thug life and the vicious cycle of
violence a high school students world is
shattered when she witnesses the fatal
shooting of her childhood best friend
and finds the courage to speak out out
of the car no stop go back where he told
you come on I'm not playing go back real
is honest and it tackles race relations
the tackles family it tackles police
brutality sounds like this ends up on
the news
people get death threats
cops target then that willingness to
stand up speak and be heard as an
evolutionary process seeing how other
people stand up in the face of power and
so where do you develop the courage to
speak out it's about how he lived his
life matter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]